bonjour roula talent jeu merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
rtl france paris et washington ont
appelé beyrouth hier soir à former un
gouvernement sans plus tarder quelle est
la réaction à cet ultimatum de la classe
politique libanaise ainsi que de la
population libanaise
je voudrais commencer par la réaction du
peuple libanais qui n'a plus du tout
confiance en cette classe politique
nous ne voyons pas l'importance de la
formation d'un gouvernement au liban
avec cette même classe politique qui a
eu l'audace de stocker le nitrate
d'ammonium dans le port de beyrouth qui
a détruit la entiers de la ville et qui
n'a rien qu'à présent pour pour pour
nous raconter qui sont les responsables
de ce crime humanitaire
cette même classe politique que
washington et paris sont en train
d'inviter à la formation du gouvernement
sont les responsables de la crise
économique financière monétaire
sanitaire au liban
comment voulez vous qu'on fasse
confiance à ces mêmes gens là résident
de farine ne paie pas la majorité du
peuple libanais de saint-amand et les
principaux donateurs de l'aide
internationale disent avoir déboursé
l'ensemble de l'enveloppé promise à la
population sinistrée
les politiques libanais dont on parle
est ce qu ils sont dos au mur maintenant
est-ce qu'ils vont agir par rapport à
cela ou bien est-ce que le statu quo va
perdurer selon vous mais même dans le
cade et de l'aide de la banque mondiale
pour les familles sinistrées il ya eu un
tas de problèmes et un tas de scandales
sur le comment ils voudraient garder les
dollars qui nous viennent de l'étranger
ce qu'on appelle en libanais le french
do ne qui vaut dix fois le dollar
libanais on l'appelle lollar c'est c'est
vraiment intellect tout neuf dans le
monde des finances et voulant dire que
la population sinistrée va recevoir 10%
seulement des aides qui sont normalement
qui devrait
arrivé il ya énormément de scandales
même dans l'ingérence de ce dossier et
au delà des scandales que vous décrivez
selon vous qu'est ce qui va se passer
ces prochains jours ses prochains
prochaines semaines ces prochains mois
le statu quo où justement des avancées
moi je crois que vu que les assassinats
des activistes comme hier monsieur slim
qui a été assassiné de sang froid
je crois qu'ils nous présentons une
déflagration d'observateurs critiquent
du hezbollah oui ça c'est inférences
critique du kivu là c'était les gens
proches de ceux là qui travaillent dans
les services de sécurité nous parle déjà
de dash voulant dire que bien on accepte
on les accepte comme le veulent ou bien
il y aura des problèmes sécuritaires et
cette fois ci évidemment ils vont en
prendre comme excuse la présence de
l'agent certaines régions bible et six
mois après l'explosion c'était le 4 août
dernier on né le 5 février c'était hier
six mois jour pour jour triste
anniversaire donc mais mais où en est la
reconstruction de la capitale libanaise
six mois après après ce drame la
capitale est encore détruites vraiment
partie n'est pas encore né incapable
incapable de retaper leur maison
détruite à cause de la crise économique
et financière en et r ça c'est d'un côté
d'un autre côté tout le monde savait
tous les responsables savaient ils ont
l'audace de passer à la télé nous dire
oui moi j'en savais mais ils n'ont rien
fait et rien ne se passera et justice ne
sera pas fait tant que ces gens-là nous
gouvernent monsieur rien ne sera fait
mais dont aucune confiance et j'espère
que paris je sais bien que le président
macron
et les français la france aime bien le
liban et s'est de même pour les libanais
qui a beaucoup la france et apprécie les
efforts mais si monsieur marc on
aimerait bien vous aider
il ya une seule façon de le faire c'est
à travers la justice suisse qui a
déclenché un processus de blanchiment
d'argent contre certains politiciens
libanais la seule façon d'aider le liban
c'est d'ouvrir
c'est ce tribunal de permettre à
l'interpol de faire appel à ces à ces
voyous qui nous gouvernent et comme cela
ils vont retrouver au moins à 100
milliards de dollars dans leurs comptes
un peu partout dans le monde cet argent
là à pourrait évidemment 2 1
elle est cassée parce que sans argent
leur leadership ne vaut rien et d'un
autre côté cet argent pourrait être
utilisée pour qu'un liban nouveau
souverain est riche nous n'avons pas
besoin de beaucoup d'argent pour
reconstruire un pays comme il faut le
liban c'est la terrasse c'est en balcon
sur la méditerranée c'est un pays
multiculturel
ne croyez pas que les gens s'entretuent
pour des raisons de religieuses ou
sectaires entre eux c'est juste les
plâtres des mafias qui sont un semblant
de protéger leur peuple mais c'est pas
c'est pas vrai du tout en le voir tous
les jours dans la rue les gens qui sont
raides sont deux sont de tous bords de
toute secte le liban est une mission sur
la méditerranée c'est un exemple nous
sommes capables de reconstruire et de
donner le bon exemple dans un monde dans
un monde qui a besoin de deux messages
de paix et un libanais sur deux vit en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté selon les
nations unies merci roue la tâche
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes analyste